good morning everyone welcome back to
the morning toast I am here with Stephen
McGee formerly of summer house formerly
thank you for joining me he will be
co-hosting the show with me today and
I'm so excited to hit you with the Fast
Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast but we have a lot
of catching up to do yeah we have a lot
of questions for you most of which we'll
get to after we hit them with the news
but first like what is new with you I'm
just really enjoying having a summer
that I get to do what I want to do
that's really nice but also it sucks
because like I feel like my friends have
been used for the past two years to
making plans without me like they just
don't invite me because they know I
couldn't come yeah so I'm like okay like
I'm here I can come out I can do things
but I've been out in the Hamptons I've
been have you run in to the summer house
crew in the Hamptons
I have purposefully avoided that that
little snafu
I have many spies throughout the
Hamptons who give me information about
their locations and where they are so
what happened because when the news came
out that you and Lauren were no longer
part of the cast it was quite shocking
right what happened well I think that
there is a lot of misinformation out
there about that first of all we were
not fired from summer house you know
this is something that like the
conversations go on for a long time and
through casting and everything there's a
lot that goes on but you know the news
broke allegedly what I've heard is that
Carl was talking to some girl you know
probably trying to impress her and
giving her a bunch of information and
her sister or someone worked at Daily
Mail and that's how the information got
out and so there was a leak Carl and it
was Carl you know he loves to talk but
that was what we were we found out that
you know we were not fired this did not
come as a surprise to me like you know I
knew that's how you found out no I I
knew like six weeks prior to it coming
out and like
you know it was I wouldn't say it was a
mutual decision but the conversations
like you know naturally came and like I
have a great relationship with Bravo I
was just at Bravo on Monday there's many
things happening with Bravo so we can
see you back we might see you back on
Bravo
yeah future but you will not see me on
summer house that book is closed okay
honestly you like I'm excited to see
what you do next the show is nothing
without you and yes I think the book is
close but it's not like reading up it's
not a book in the Harry Potter series
like you know that's a book you put away
that's the book that goes to the art
sale right exactly so thank you for the
update we will get into the more
in-depth questions later but before that
we are here to hit you with the best
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and stephen is
here to help me help you at first i am a
little bit confused because you know i
automatically always thought of toast
like whenever i think of the morning
toast i think of like i want your like
picture to be like you know The Brave
Little Toaster or something but then I
was like oh no it's totally about
drinking in the morning
well so is it about eating or drinking
it's about all forms of toast about
toasting it's about a piece of toast and
it just has multiplied --k a lot of
different uses and anyway toasting
whatever way it speaks to you that for
me it's alcohol right for sometimes for
us it's alcohol and sometimes for us
it's like avocado toast okay you know
sometimes it's also a sony morgan
toaster so verse we're so versatile and
and then it's also the toast is now
toasty vibes yeah so it means a lot of
different things but thank you I feel
like a lot of people have had that
question and we've never gotten a chance
to address it up it is all things toast
you guys it's the bread it's the drinks
it's the tip I'm just like mind-blowing
thank you okay so first story last night
where the ESPY Awards Danica Patrick
hosted I heard she did a mediocre job
but the real moment was Aly Raisman in
140 of Larry Nasser's victims United
onstage quote we survived together they
said so in one of the most powerful and
emotional moments in the ESPY Awards
history more than 100 survivors of the
disgraced dr. Larry Nasser who is vile
and disgusting and I hate
even have to talk about it on the show
anymore were honored for their courage
in making their stories heard even when
no one would listen Jennifer Garner
presented the Arthur Ashe Courage Award
to the one hundred and forty of the
hundreds of child athletes who have
spoken out about the horrific sexual
abuse they experienced drought under the
care of the now imprisoned Michigan
State and USA Gymnastics doctor the
group of victims including Olympic gold
medalist Ali Reis Minh took to the stage
after a heart-wrenching video
introduction as the large group of quote
sister survivors made their way onto the
stage at the Microsoft theater they were
given a standing ovation by the
country's top sport stars many of whom
stop clapping only to wipe away their
tears three of masters victims race
Mancera Klein and Tiffany Lopez
described the horrific experience of
being ignored when they reported sexual
abuse quote the ripple effects of our
actions or inactions can be enormous
spanning generations perhaps the
greatest tragedy of this nightmare is
that it could have been avoided Raceland
said agree quote whether you act or do
nothing you are shaping the world that
we live in impacting others all we
needed was one adult to have the
integrity stand between us and Larry
Nasser she added if just one adult had
listened believed and acted the people
standing before you on the stage
wouldn't have never met him I love Ali
Reis man like oh my god I love her so
much I love her percent well first of
all being strong enough to like take the
stage with our her sister survivors and
like really have a moment and it just
empower other people but like for
stating the obvious which is that so
many people complained about this doctor
and no one did anything like it goes so
far up to the top right it's so
disgusting and I'm glad she called it
out onstage in front of the like the
largest widest sports audience that
exists yeah I think what we found lately
is that like we need people to be
putting these people on blast in public
forums because that's the only way that
we as a public have to hold them
accountable exactly it's like because
the people who are above that won't hold
them accountable it's not until it's a
big national scandal that people give a
[ __ ] and it's it's really frustrating
because you would think people in power
like would use that power right I mean
especially with kids you have to really
be a shitty person to turn a blind eye
when you're talking about kids that are
like
and so yeah so young hundreds of kids
like this is systematic and it's it's
horrible and I'm glad that these women
have had their day but honestly it's not
enough justice being served like it's a
start right
the Arthur Ashe Courage Award is a start
yeah I mean I think that that is like
the least that that community can do for
these people but agree the guys
something at least and I'm it's bringing
awareness to the issue and that helps
but right we need to do better you guys
USA Gymnastics Michigan State do better
by our children thank you all so
switching gears a little bit something a
little bit more exciting Danica Patrick
and Aaron Rodgers like made their
red-carpet couple debut and we have a
photo of them like there you look really
cute I don't know how I feel about them
as a couple just cuz I'd like read a lot
of blind items do you keep up with blind
items so I only started reading the
blinds because of because of that one
blind that everyone said was about
summer house oh my god right so there's
a blind item
hi auntie and it was like it was never
solved I don't think but it said this
reality TV show and it made it seem like
like we guessed it was that summer house
basically there was this because it came
out the next week but the blind came out
the next week after the Daily Mail
article Oh right climate rising like the
show was canceled because there was a
video of the cast members like yeah so
instead of FINA cancelling they just got
rid of half the cast or something right
so it wasn't about summer house but
Stephen said it was not the dad got him
into blind items yeah so the blinds have
said some curious things about Aaron
Rodgers Olivia Munn that whole deal um I
don't know I don't know what to think
I like danica Patrick's GoDaddy
commercial that's all I'll say yeah but
like do better than GoDaddy that's true
but she's making like GoDaddy seem cool
yeah you know also that's probably some
serious money
so like also can I do it GoDaddy
commercial and and II also just revealed
a buying that she like does all of these
endorsements like one after the other
after the other and she's just like
making so much money
making her seem like she does really
well in her career as a driver but that
may not be the case me right but I don't
know about driving right also though the
fact that we even care about a driver
like we like that we're talking about a
driver yeah we're not in like Talladega
Alabama no but there is she really is
like you know bringing NASCAR to a lot
of people which is really cool also
speaking of the SVS I found last night I
didn't watch the actual words just
highlights on Twitter but an Instagram
but I feel like the ESPYs were like
really in tune with what was necessary
last night like so many of the people
who were there like re The Bachelor cuz
he is like a Formula One driver so he
was there with his new fiance which was
really cute they looked so glamorous and
of course you know this Ally Reisman 140
survivors were like got the Arthur Ashe
award I feel like they asked me to a
really nice job of like being in tune
with what's necessary and like being
culturally relevant yeah I think the
thing that set that all out there was
Caitlyn Jenner I told you ever really
whine about the ESPYs for Caitlyn Jenner
showed up I totally agree and then
lately it's been like ever watch and I
was like and I felt like at the time wow
this is so great for the ESPYs that like
Caitlyn Jenner is really bringing so
much awareness to this award show and
then every year since I've been like
that yes these are really culturally
relevant there's always a really big
sports story happening yeah and this
year again I believe like it's the case
and I'm just really happy for the ESPYs
for getting their shine yeah because
also like sports I think there's so many
award shows and I'm not an award show
person I talk about this all the time
like you're actors who need multiple
award shows for doing their job which is
very easy and they're overpaid you don't
know to also be celebrated right but
sports athletes work very very hard
they're like the number one in their
field in their craft in the world and
it's nice that we recognize them
sometimes and people really care about
their athletes I mean I could give a
[ __ ] if Tom Cruise or whoever like
whatever they do like I mean yeah I
liked your movie but good aw I don't
need to watch three different award
shows like talking about the movie yeah
speaking of movies okay so this week I'm
the toast claudia was about to spoil the
plot of shutter island
and which I had never seen and then I
was like wait I was like wait now I kind
of want to see it so don't spoil it and
she's given me a week to watch it so I
started watching it last night and I
don't know what I was saying cameras
alone in the dark and I just couldn't
say it's kind of creepy it's really
creepy and I also didn't realize that it
had like Holocaust elements in it and I
just I I wasn't in Holocaust mode you
know so every time I had to like I went
back I was not it takes I have to like
gear up to watch a holocaust film like
it's so painful and pit worthy and I
didn't know that's what I was watching I
thought I was just watching like a
twisted mental hospital so I had to
leave and watch her Honi which really
brought me back slides and I was like
you know what I could do more Shelter
Island and they put it on it's like a
pile of bodies at Auschwitz and like the
girl wakes up and I'm just thinking no
back to her Honi so I'm almost done with
shutter island'
we'll talk about it with Claudia next
week but I just wanted you guys to know
I do not take this job lately and I'm
going to watch the rest of the movie in
the day it's pretty good enjoying it
yeah it's creepy I don't know how you
could watch it like in segments like I
know because now all day I'm seeing
what's the twist what's the twist like
who did it who done it look what's going
on and now I'm when I started the movie
I was like wow I really want to know
what happens and I'll find out then in
two hours yeah but I didn't know it's
been 12 hours it really reminds me of
did you watch a cure for wellness no
what's that it's like another it's like
very similar in the idea of like there's
like this like place that people go to
and I don't know if I can tell you
without without sweating yeah I
appreciate that but he's a big spoiler
it's weird like that and it has a
similar vibe okay so you like watch so
far the jury is still out
it's very very weird I was really drunk
when I watched it but I was actually on
a date with someone who was sober and I
felt bad for them but no no no I don't
care for what they're all very weird I
mean watch movies drunk really easily
really I feel like I can barely watch TV
drunk like I forget everything that
happens and then when I do watch it
again I'm like oh I already saw this but
I didn't like ingest it young I don't
know I don't know I guess I'm just
really like you know you're just so I'm
a great drop your profession
amazing anyways stay tuned on cheddar
island we'll be talking about Mahoney
after the past side okay this next story
is hilarious and really sad post Malone
says people think I'm ugly and I smell
so this is actually my favorite story
about the headlock yes rapper post
Malone knows for his hits rock star and
psycho was the subject of much
conversation on Twitter this week when
the cast of queer I announced they'll be
shooting the show's third season in
Kansas City fans on Twitter began
nominating Malone for a makeover
the 23 year old star is known for his
blinged out teeth tattoos and messy hair
to put it lightly page six that's very
kind
quote why does everyone want post Malone
to be on the show Kurama brown asked did
he request it malone tweeted back what
he believes is the motivation behind his
nomination no they just think I'm ugly
and smell lol and Malone quipped love
the show though guys keep crushing it
and then Kurama wrote back you keep
killing it - I personally love your
style and music this is really sad
because as someone who is in the morning
Twitter Facebook groups I'm very in tune
with what you know so am i I know we
need to talk about you being a toaster
which is I think that where as toasters
beers are so honored to have you and
every time you like chime in on a post
like about stress or something I'm like
I try not to do it too much because I
don't want you to feel infiltrated I
love the perfect I check it every day I
mean how could you know multiple times
multiple times a day and toasters are
kind of always going in on post Malone
saying I keep up smells bad and post
Malone knows he has heard your cries and
it's honestly kind of sad has anyone
ever smelled post Malone like aura we're
just going off of photos this is like an
Andy this is such a like watch Rabin's
live question where he's like how did
Oprah smell right but you're like how do
possible smell right if anyone has
smelled post Malone can you please write
in the comments someone have been nice
thing to me on Instagram story today
they wrote I was doing my lipstick video
and they were like you look like you
smell good
thank you that is a nicest compliment I
don't even know that I do but I'm glad
that I look like it I'm the anti post
Malone yeah you are
I would love you should queer ahem yeah
I would like ahh ok you do a makeover
series a toast makeover I would love to
do a toast makeover series but what's
interesting is that I have absolutely no
like sense of men's fashion like when
Zach asked me what tie to wear like does
this shirt work with these pants like
for the when it's pretty simple it's
like you know Paris like suit pants and
a t-shirt like ok no that doesn't work
but I really don't like I can't dress
men yeah like it does this time I could
just do like colors I know what you can
tell people when they look bad right I
just don't know really men's style so I
don't even know that I would be good at
making a very is like a looser makeover
puts Milan maybe maybe I mean if he
showers right well we don't even have
confirmation that he smells bad you know
like maybe he doesn't like maybe he
tries to look like that every day and
what is our what is what is bad okay
that is be Oh bad breath like smelly
hair
he definitely I know I know I feel bad
now we yourself into who what was that
big scandal about someone who said their
hair smelled it was a girl of female
celebrities zendaya zendaya oh that's so
true wait where Liza faded by post
Malone but we can't say it everyone went
up to zendaya zendaya Zadeh what is I
don't know zendaya zendaya everyone went
up for her and was like defending her
and here they are just drawing him under
the bus it's really true and it's like
he knows that you think that he smells
which makes me feel like he doesn't
smell because smelly people usually are
very not self-aware
right yeah if you smell it's usually an
accident right or a fetish so I'm gonna
get around some of that justice for post
Malone because we do not have
confirmation that he smells so what's up
saying that he does yeah well and he
took it on the chin he was behind it
totally and don't judge a book by it's
cover you guys maybe I smell really bad
you never know right people love your
makeup videos my friend faith she
actually texted me today just like tell
her I bought her
I don't know something you did I don't
know foundation or something and I
follow your beauty routine people love
here oh my god thank you I love like
Beauty seven I also love watching other
people's be like I love watching Kylie
do her makeup so when people tell me I
love watching you do your makeup it's
soothing I'm like I know exactly how you
feel like I feel that way too you start
doing like fragrance for tutorials like
I'm Ashley I'm not a fragrance expert I
feel like any time I wear perfume which
I forget to do like most days it comes
off in five minutes even when I spray a
lot and then when I spray too much I'm
like and making myself nauseous and it
doesn't you just get used to the smell I
don't think it like comes off I don't
think it just dusts off of you it
doesn't stick honey
or maybe I'm not spraying enough huh
what's wrong with your skin I don't know
it just doesn't absorb what I get just
like maybe radiates off I don't know or
maybe that I'm just I just feel the way
I think they might not spread enough cuz
Zack like wears lot of Cologne he has
like his signature smell and sometimes
I'll hear him putting it on and I'm like
whoa like that's so much like that I've
been other names like you just did like
20 Springs but now I get that's crazy I
know why you leave a trail of the
Cologne behind you yeah I feel like I
get like wild if I do two sprays whoa
I'm gonna meet someone tonight yeah yeah
we need like to come up with a number of
sprays that is appropriate do you
remember that kid in high school that
like had that Axe body spray that has
rich mom bottom like you know that's you
just knew when they were coming down the
hall right when you walk past an
Abercrombie store and like it smells
yeah
even on Fifth Avenue like when you walk
past like they have you the open air in
the open in your city smelly hot streets
you have managed to make a corner of New
York smelly abaca me a [ __ ] like if I
was standing by the store and someone
just [ __ ] right next to me I would still
smell a store they must have it like
pumping through the through the been you
know so I actually was a employee of
Hollister and they like they have a
different it's not the actual cologne or
perfume but they have a different watt
don't spray that they walk around and
spray on all the clothes like every like
30 minutes that's why your clothes
smells like the store for like the first
five washes that's crazy yeah I guess it
works also why it may be discolored
right and a lot of other things and like
attract mosquitoes yeah I just that's so
crazy to me but it I guess it works
anyway yeah I don't think he smells I
don't think I'm going no smell no smell
Malone okay next up we have to like
subset stories first story number three
because they're both about Miley Cyrus
and they both might be fake news no so
the first one is about Miley and Liam
Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth split
says the Daily Mail and not many other
sources are saying this that's why I'm
very cautious about reporting it because
I don't think it's true singer an actor
call it a day amid Rose over when to
start a family so Daily Mail is saying
that they have canceled the wedding
because they can't agree on when to have
babies however I was under the
impression that they are already married
I mean but of all the things like that's
what's gonna break them up they have
come through so much so they went
through Miley is weird you know tonk
series I think they went through
barriers she went through Miley Cyrus
and her dead pets together you think
through this no way they can't get over
that and I don't think I mean if
anything I guess Liam probably wants to
start a family before Miley would be my
guess right what is a bit like also
that's yeah that's not really if the
girl was was older and the guy was
cinder you know girl you have a clock
it's sure you have a clock I mean he can
keep going right so like I don't see
anybody breaking up over that I I don't
think they're broke up and I I read
somewhere I don't know if it was a blind
or something or just like word on the
street but I heard that they were
already married so for them to write
canceling their wedding day right they
were married but didn't have the
ceremony or something right that was
like a long time ago too and what's also
curious about the story is like daily
news reporting it so then like some fake
sites picked it up too but like he's not
reporting at TMZ is not reporting it so
I am just going to
not believe it quite yet yeah also I
someone one of the toaster said I guess
wells from The Bachelor said on his
podcast or something that um that Miley
and Liam worked that he read that Miley
and Liam were going through it and then
he went to a 4th of July party at brandy
Cyrus's house and Miley and Liam were
there happy as ever so like you can't
believe everything that you read
especially if you don't read it right
and I honestly feel like the Miley Cyrus
that the world is giving us right now is
the best Miley we've ever gotten
like I just I'm so happy that we're here
it's honestly the best since like party
in the USA yeah yard sessions Jolin that
was right peak Miley but she said so
they'll be trying up to yeah I mean
can't be tamed was like it was like I
liked that Miley about because it was
like you're a little dirty no totally
like really dirty
but I think I'm holding out hope for
these two also what's curious is that
she completely wiped her Instagram
Taylor Swift style delete all of her
photos but people are like what is the
meaning I'm sure just know I mean that's
like a regular thing now although I
don't want us to rebrand from Malibu
Malibu Miley like I don't want us to
refrain from that like maybe enhance it
but not a rebrand right if we get
another bangers I'm done and it's like
she doesn't need to have like a Taylor
Swift she's dead ocean moment she hasn't
been in a scandal or right but maybe
it's this the scandal is this what she
needs me guys she's going through a
divorce they've been together for so
long
the last song 2009 that's crazy
the last song that's where they met huh
when the waves did you sing well maybe I
feel like you would but I don't know
that song oh my god it's so good and you
know what I can't do it justice and
you're going to I can only sing it like
the climb the climb era was I loved that
okay I think about Miley did have a good
time she did know she definitely ups and
downs it's definitely
a coaster but she's like she's peeking
she's peeking so I hope everything's
okay with her and so now we have some
more positive Miley Cyrus rumored news
Taylor Swift might be recording a new
song with mice Miley Cyrus and Lady gaga
so the only information that we have on
this is that Taylor Swift has been
spotted entering a recording studio in
New York and it's led fans to wonder
about a possible collab the singer was
pictured entering Electric Lady studios
where Miley Cyrus and Lady Gaga are
currently working on new music people
are speculating that Taylor's laying
down vocals for a new song featuring one
or both of the artists which let's face
it would be the best news ever
who says big top 40 calm so no real news
outlets are reporting on this except for
the morning tour because they're in tune
with what's necessary it's mostly
Twitter speculated on that Twitter
exactly but you know I think if we could
get a bang bang but with like people
that we really like I mean it would be
epic
it would almost be like there is some
such thing as like too much of a good
thing and it helps me the greatest song
of all time or it would be the worst
right you know which either way I would
love it right and you know what these
three women are not gonna let it be the
worst like they they're each so talented
in their own right like Lady Gaga is not
putting out a shitty song she's
definitely not because you know Joanne
I'm Pro n I mean I love Joanne it wasn't
the worst but like like it was just if I
mean artpop was the worst we talked
about this yesterday yeah are you proud
art pop I had moments that I liked but
as a whole you know I haven't gone back
to that in my library in a long time you
never except for that one song gypsy
gypsy I can play that on the piano and
I'm like oh my god I love that song yeah
I recently watched that video of her and
Christina singing do what you want with
my body and just was disturbed yeah that
was that was about do what you want with
my body I want to close it and put it
away yeah that was tough so I loved
Johanna and I feel like it set her up
really nicely for whatever's next you
know see like kind of it was like a
rebirth yeah
please now we can get him back into you
know I would like a little bit of freaky
Gaga back but like not too much that's
ridiculous just like in the pre-show an
era she looks like very much jean shorts
t-shirt like down-home country yeah and
now like her vibe is glamour again like
yeah she Young's sad I want a micro dose
the crazy right I feel like that's what
we're getting yeah and if these three
come together for a song like I don't
know who to thank but thank you and I'll
just stay tuned I know I might actually
start believing in God again no that
would be so crazy and it's like why
these three you know like what do Miley
and Taylor like they have beef they
perform 15 together at the Grammys and I
never spoke again you know yeah they
couldn't be more different
I mean I can actually Miley and Gaga
together that would be that alone would
be great
Oh totally so like what does Taylor
Swift have to do with this I I know I
can hear Miley and Gaga giving like some
great voices and then Taylor Swift just
being like yeah or like maybe she wrote
the song maybe he was like a Calvin
Harris what's that song look oh yeah
this is what you came for you just sort
of thing maybe what was her I forgot to
say denial sergeant and something I
don't know anyway stay tuned for updates
on this developing story I hope it is
true that it's not too long I don't have
to wait till the Sun comes out
we are you still think do you think that
we have a song in the summer I was
talking about this with my friends this
weekend I do
I think the song of the summer it is the
middle Maren Morris let's go because
like his last summer was desperate Oh
unequivocally and everyone say no when
the middle came out with a spring like
this along with summer but does the
season came out in the winter and it's
like I said build-up before it's playing
everywhere all right
it needs to be in Starbucks it needs to
be in the clothing stores in the nursing
home I need to be everywhere everywhere
and I feel like the middle is everywhere
some other contenders they were saying
one kiss bye do Lippa I still think it's
too much like a cool song it hasn't paid
masses I don't think that's it and then
oh the cardi B song with [ __ ] what's it
called I don't even know what it's also
I can't
summer yeah I think it's called I like
it I've been hoping for a big banger
from Ariana sweetener you know I love
God as a woman but it's not something
summer material no totally the others no
cheer softer cry is good Ultron song I'm
the summer material the cardi B song is
I like it and they think that might be
the song of the summer but I just feel
like I'm hearing the middle more yeah I
guess we still have time hotel
time will tell I I'm just curious to
hear what the toaster say people are
saying I like it
ok I would say I'd be okay with that
yeah I just feel like further something
but summer like it's not bothering me
enough you know right I still feel like
every time I hear it I'm like I'm like
realizing new lyrics whereas this is
like I need to know all the words
right so I don't know but I would be
here for it a little cardi B song in the
summer but also mario song in the summer
she deserves it too like that would be
crazy she goes through me and like a
low-key hipster country singer one day
and now she's has the song in the summer
right yeah I mean I don't even know who
she is she's a country aside from the
middle right I mean you would actually
really like her she's so talented and
I'm so happy for her and eleven other
stuff like pop stars audition for that
song and for one reason or another
didn't work out with them either like
yeah then and Greg I think it's a pair
of brothers okay Oh
in my feelings might be the song of the
summer but I feel like it started too
late like I liked it and I feel a
challenge I love watching the videos but
maybe just because I just well only when
they're good like I started the only
video I like is that mom that had her
daughter doing it on the street and she
driveway and laughter but I like oh my
god that's hilarious
no I just love like people dancing and
assuming they're good dancers I think
it's like really cute and I love when
like the world comes together on
something like so fun and pure no and
you know harp okay well then you're
gonna totally disagree with me but you
know what it reminds me of which I'm
like hell no happy' by pharrell
which I if I hear that song again I'll
still kill myself
I like like now it's like okay I'm over
that song but at the time like if we're
all just dancing to a song called happy
I'm cool with that you know but it's
like why put on a front I'm not happy I
just like that's what I want to do jazz
squares yeah like a Bach fine
oh my god one of my favorite day
speaking of sharp a like that [ __ ]
asked me questions thing on Instagram
kills me
like have you done it I've not done it
but I guess maybe I followed too many
gay people because there's so many
people there like ask me anything and
it's like dick size or whatever and like
they answer all these questions I'm like
who are you even and you should ask that
I watched I watched Ashley Tisdale oh my
and someone asked her like if you
weren't Sharpay who would you want to be
and she's like I can't believe anyone
but Sharpay that [ __ ] was made for me
no and that's hilarious
sure justice for Ashley Tisdale justice
verax we did sell interest this first
hour pay because like we've talked about
this on the show and there is like this
running theory that like Sharpay was
really like the protagonist like she
works so hard in her life to just be in
the show and like this nobody comes up
out of nowhere barely audition did you
start that because I saw in the BuzzFeed
article yesterday oh no it was a twitter
thread that i read last year they come
up they can't even sing they don't it's
like she's prioritizing science over the
musical and it's like if you want to be
in the musical like this needs to be
your life like you need to take this
[ __ ] seriously you can't be having a
basketball game and then come to
second-round auditions so and then like
when she's trying to get in the sequel
when she's trying to get help Zac Efron
it's like she's just trying to help him
get into a better college right and
she's like demonized I don't know so I
feel like Sharpay's really misunderstood
but I like I like High School Musical
the way it is too
yeah yeah yeah high school 3 it's just a
master I would love us to have a high
school musical fact no like I feel like
it could happen with all these reunions
in these reboots because no one can
think of anything original like right
High School Musical 4 isn't so far that
like huh
I thought we did have 4 wasn't for
graduation no 3 was okay he was in
theaters I would like us to have like
High School Musical midlife crisis
musical like night school yeah high
school like I'm getting my masters
online yeah that would be magical that
would be literally none of them are
together they just perform songs like on
group face times oh yes
Skype high schools like all internet
that's incredible
also I was watching to send in this last
night which some people say is like the
modern High School Musical it's like a
Disney Channel movie it's called
descendants it's amazing there's
descendants and since oh yeah I heard
about that from some of the blinds just
finished shooting descendants three
which I'm hoping is gonna be in theaters
because it's just so masterful and I'm
just so excited I love it I don't know I
don't know if I should recommend it to
you because it's like a very is it a
decom it's a decom okay and I just
downloaded the Disney app on my Apple TV
so now I have access to all these d coms
and I have to be honest what like
looking at all the titles with the
blinds in the back of my head like yeah
I was a little sick to my stomach right
but I I found a way to enjoy descendants
what what would be what's really
favorite old decom ooh okay I love wish
upon a star like I was Katherine Heigl I
feel like it's just so underrated and so
amazing
who how do you feel about the light size
remake okay this is what life-size is a
perfect movie in like I understand why
they would feel the need to bring it
back and ruin it
right make it me for TV without Lindsay
Lohan on freeform during Christmas
question mark like right I would
literally rather see Lindsay Lohan back
on it and some new Barbie right no Tyra
or just for the two of them like let's
make it work you guys there has to be a
paycheck big enough for the both of you
you know I can't I be filmed in like
Greece or something wait totally so I'm
here for it just
like sure I don't think it's gonna be
very good but I'll watch it okay and I
appreciate that they understand that
it's a great movie and there's a need to
bring back because they did not reorder
enough right but I mean the song I know
the song
Eve's great no matter where she goes
from our head to our toes in the mall in
the gosh fashion after dark either don't
you spend the whole night dancing shine
bright shiny bar don't be shocked being
stuck where you live where you are being
star I mean however we better get
another thought we better oh my god
we're not going to I feel but the sequel
is also giving me like Legally Blonde
vibe so you ever see that movie where as
I supposed to be the sequel to Legally
Blonde is club legally blondes with the
two twins from sweet life and it's like
Reese Witherspoon has definitely never
even heard of it so it makes me feel a
little bit back in Cody yes those twin
girls were like so pretty no not second
Cody's of the twins from sweet life this
non deck whatever twins this twin girl
almost sort of below decks below deck is
like a charter passenger yeah but that
takes some money oh you know probably
didn't pay that money that's crazy like
I feel like it's crazy that they
actually pay for the boat and you get a
major discount oh and you're also paying
to be on TV which like really that's the
only thing like right can't buy I do
always wonder like what's in that tip
envelope if it's really money or if it's
just like stuff with like coupons or
something well right like and also it's
like you're going on TV you know you're
gonna be entering you know that the plot
really ends with how big your tip is
right how do you possibly give a bad tip
I did actually get some intel on
remember on the season premiere there
was that woman effort it was the
terrible group of passengers who were
like we need our nuts and like I don't
like lobster but I love shellfish but I
hate seafood and like that woman's life
got ruined somebody found her and like I
just made that met her and
Lana and she was like I did this Bing
she's like I digitally all my social
media everything that's the kind of sad
but but you also hard to not be an
[ __ ] right and you ever watch the
show right even if you are an [ __ ]
like deep to your core you know you're
gonna be on TV like have just a little
Sun awareness to know like oh maybe I
shouldn't act this right this was always
like a thing on summer house whenever
our friends would come or something and
they're like well I just don't want to
be and we're like they're not focused on
you like but if you do something bad I
was like the only way the camera is
gonna really be on you is if you throw a
drink on somebody or something I'm like
if you do something bad they're gonna
throw you under the bus because they
don't care about you right you're not
gonna be around so they're gonna make
you look like an [ __ ] and so I would
crap my friends like don't don't you
know be an [ __ ] because you will be
an [ __ ] on TV if you walk totally
that's so scary and like the fact that
he doesn't air for so long it's like did
I make it did I not right and like you
thought like maybe I'm gonna be okay you
forgot about it
yeah maybe American would fall in love
with me no not gonna happen guys okay
next story is really sad Lea Michele
broke the news of Cory Monteith's death
to his mom Ann McGregor will never
forget the day she learned her son Glee
star Cory Monteith died of a heroin
overdose in 2013 at age 31 quote I got
the call from Lea Michele and she was
screaming on the phone the 67 year old
told People magazine on Wednesday she
was yelling is it true is it true about
Cory and I said what about Cory
I had heard nothing and then the police
knocked on my front door I went into a
state of numbness she said I just shut
off all emotions and I was numb the pain
of losing her son only intensified as
days and weeks passed I knew it was real
but there were times when I could lie to
myself and say he's in LA he'll call me
soon said McGregor I'm still always
hanging on the edge when you lose
someone who was such a big part of you
you lose all purpose for living the TV
star what a long history of drug use
have been in rehab three times was found
dead in a Vancouver hotel room with
traces of morphine codeine and heroin
present in his body before his Saturn
death the actor was thinking about the
future and what had held for him Cory
wanted a wife and kids and system
McGregor he would have made a beautiful
father he had accomplished so much he
was ready to step out of Hollywood and
really live he had so much to look
forward to Cory didn't want to die there
was no doubt about that but he's carried
in people's hearts forever
this is so sad like Cory Monteith like
was so beloved and I just feels like
this story was so sad I feel like it
really was the beginning of like the
Glee curse yeah and there is a curse he
seemed so nice and so like innocent I
mean I don't know how that's in real
life but just this character and how he
I don't know I don't think you could be
so passive like he must have really had
some demons but it I read another thing
about that that she said like it all
kind of the whole downfall stemmed from
some dental work he had just had and I
guess he had had dental work in the few
weeks before and it got him put on some
kind of medication or painkiller oh my
god yeah it's like what ledge that's
what it says hey terrible oh my god I
was about to go to the dentist every lap
not happening well do you know did he
have a heroin problem before yeah yeah
baby relapsed he was sober and like as
long as you don't have a heroin check
that like as long as you don't have a
problem then he should be fine but they
didn't work okay that's great you didn't
die from the dentist but it just it yeah
it like triggers his relapse oh my god
that is so sad and so she says like
because he had been sober for so long he
had built up an intolerance to the drug
like you know when you start doing it
you do more and more and more and I
guess he went back to like his what she
suspect says he went back to like his
old dosage and he couldn't handle it and
that's why he went into cardiac arrest
oh my goodness that is so sad
yeah but it did just like tip off I mean
we've had a lot of Glee right well
here's the thing so there's this
definitely Glee curse where a lot of the
cast members have you know assembled
into unfortunate circumstances some more
so than others Cory Monteith and then
there's like Mark Salling who there's a
lot of speculation about what actually
happened to him and I feel like it's not
a curse when you can trace when it's not
just like spooky mystery when it's like
you can trace it all right back to one
person maybe you know like I was
reading so we were talking about the
movie poltergeist and how the little
girl from from the 80s
the little girl from poltergeist was
raped to death on set and they said that
you know it was just like a mystery she
like had a stomach problem and she died
and then they started to put all this
stuff out that it worked there was like
a poltergeist curse on set like the
spookiness of the movie was overflowing
into the set and it's like no if you
like look at everything that happened
people didn't just die mysteriously like
things happen yeah so when I say Glee
curse I take that with a grain of salt
so what do you think extend at all I
don't know I just feel like Hollywood is
so corrupt you guys yes and I do think
part of it goes back to like you know
there is something to say about are
these kids who are kind of born and bred
in the industry because they are more
these people found fame huge fame from
nothing like they everyone on the show
was pretty for the most part
undiscovered and they were discovered on
the show and they found massive amounts
of fame so obviously there's gonna be
skeletons in the closet and it's gonna
be a little overwhelming yeah like just
hard to deal with Cory's mom said he
just wasn't ready for the Hollywood
lifestyle yeah
which is really sad no Hollywood
lifestyle needs to change you guys or
else we're gonna be reporting more sad
stories okay fifth and final story kind
of interesting I'm like on a Leo kick
because I'm in the middle of shutter
island' Brad Pitt and Leonardo DiCaprio
turned down Brokeback Mountain don't
worry he won't get far on foot director
Gus Van Sant reveals in an interview
with indieWIRE that both Brad Pitt and
Leonardo DiCaprio passed on Brokeback
Mountain the gay love story that snagged
eight Academy Award nominations in 2006
the most of any film that year Van Sant
who was approached to direct the film
that was ultimately helmed by Angley
recalled the lack of interest from
actors in for trying the roles that
Ernie Jake Gyllenhaal and Heath Ledger
widespread acclaim and accolades nobody
wanted to do it Vance and said I was
working on it and I felt like we really
needed a strong cast like a famous cast
that wasn't working out I asked the
usual suspects Leonardo DiCaprio Brad
Pitt Matt Damon Ryan's little P they all
said no Diana Isana who produced the
film with James Sheamus for Focus
Features confirmed and sans casting
revelations in an email sent to
any wire yes all those young gentlemen
at the time shade turn down the project
for various reasons she wrote o sana
also adopted the script with Larry
McMurtry by Annie Proulx of the two
leading men Ledger's what was a more
difficult to fill according to asana
casting enos in particular was the
ultimate hurdle she said looking back on
the lack of enthusiasm surrounding the
film's casting process at the time vance
and said what i could have done and what
i probably should have done was cast
more unknowns not worried about the who
the lead actors were he continued it was
not ready I'm not sure why there was
just sort of a hiccup on my part there
was something off with myself I guess
whatever was going on that's so
interesting I have to be honest I didn't
see Brokeback Mountain either I've only
seen it in like segments like when it's
been airing on TV like I'll catch the
beginning here I'll catch the end or
something about I feel like you never
watch like really critically acclaimed
films like right from start to finish
one also I know what gay sex is like
[Laughter]
that's pretty much just like I know it's
about more than that but right I don't
know really know like I mean I don't
know what the story is about other than
these two men coming together maybe
after I watch Sodor island I should just
go on a hole Leo terror of all the
actually no he wasn't in this movie but
maybe I just go on a whole critically
acclaimed movie terror of all the good
movies that I missed right I've missed a
lot whenever people ask me I'm like I
know I feel like all of the like Oscar
movies I feel like there was two years
maybe where I'd seen a lot when like
Jennifer Lawrence necessarily popping
off but now not so much yeah I saw three
billboards I just watched that too and I
like I finally watched greatest showmen
what did you think I liked it I was
really drunk and I cried a lot oh my god
when did you cry which parts from about
three minutes and until the end
no the one time I cried what the first
time I watched it was in the song
million dreams when he is like being
kicked to the ground for stealing a
piece of bread and then I was like oh my
gosh I can't cry it's the beginning so
then then I like stopped myself from
crying more and then I didn't cry for
the rest because it's just like so
positive and beautiful right but it was
like you know
I'm just like it really is the greatest
show oh my god this is me
oh hi everything I was like what's your
favorite song from it I mean it has to
be this mean I agree I I think this is
me and the greatest show are the two
like most popular songs but they're also
really the two best songs also never
ever anything's good I actually when I
was listening to never enough on the
soundtrack before I saw it I was more
impressed with it than when I saw it I
made it a point not to listen to the
soundtrack before I watch a movie
because like I knew I would enjoyed so
much more hearing these songs for the
first time and after having seen the
movie now probably like 10 times and
listening to soundtrack on repeat I can
say with certainty that rewrite the
stars is the most overrated song ever
yeah people are up so obsessed with it
and it's like every time it starts
playing I'm like nah yeah honestly the
whole that whole love story I really
just did not even pay attention to it I
mean I like it was really sweet and I
feel like it was definitely for you know
the younger generation who doesn't like
give a fart about Hugh Jackman and
Michelle Williams
right but I don't know it's just that
one song I just if it was if people
weren't so like pretending like it was
the best song ever
maybe I would like it more but it's just
annoying me now right because you think
it's so good but it's really not that's
really not an you think tightrope is so
bad but it's really not it's a really
pretty song yeah I think I think it was
a good movie especially for a music
movie musical and it was very fast-paced
yeah and it's just like a showstopper
and other things like I love when you
can see like I have the money don't
create a show right it was the greatest
showstopper I love when you can see all
the money that was spent you know like
right in some ways I love seeing money
right like it's like the budget for this
film is all seen I feel like something
like indie movies or whatever have like
big budgets and it's like but you're on
dirt road right where's the money but
those people the people that wrote it
passed compiled a like la-la-land
DeRozan I think there's a Christmas
Story the musical figure out
the live musical I think they did work
on that yeah cuz it was awesome they
made it it was a Broadway musical and I
think that they adapted the Broadway
musical for they wrote the Broadway
musical version I think they adapted
that for the la langue oh and that is
where they did a live commercial for
greatest showman in the murder of a
Christmas story before greatest showman
came out and it was just like a really
cool vertical integration yeah love some
vertical integration do you ever see 30
rock
I did see 30 rock I was on the season
finale of season 4 what yeah what were
you doing
it's cerise wedding episode with the
Somali pirates and and Matt Damon is on
the episode I was well who were you um
well I was actually supposed to
allegedly be the brother of the groom
but all my lines got cut I did a
5-minute little filming I did five lines
with Tina Fey and one time I saw her in
an event and she waved at me oh my god
are you an actor I was like I when I
first moved here it was like literally I
was here for like four months and it was
doing smash I got it I was basically
doing anything with money totally
understand
yeah anything that had money I did it
exciting any other roles that we would
know I was on an episode of The Good
Wife with what's-her-name iCarly
Randy cosmic yeah Miranda oh how was she
she was really nice that's Josh she was
very nice but like very young and kind
of weird hilarious oh my god that's so
exciting
okay speaking of questions for you we
have a lot of viewer questions that I
would be remiss if I did not ask right
because everyone who's been waiting to
hear from you
we're gonna get a little bit more in
depth about summer house I know that you
have some tea to spill because you
always do yeah so let's get right into
it what happened that caused like why
would they keep Carl and Kyle and let go
of you guys so basically you know at the
end of last season I think we had our
friend group was pretty
fractured and then we went all winter
and through the airing it was like we
kind of were being cordial and and we
were making it work you know but when it
started airing there were just a lot of
issues and a lot of problems and you
know what made it on the show ultimately
I think was a different version of what
really happened in some cases that
really and we know that that happens on
shows but when you get a good at it you
don't really throw it in the other
people's faces you know you sit there
and you be quiet and you be happy that
you got the good a default count your
blessings and I think our group just got
really fractured and after we found the
reunion which was pretty tense you know
I don't think that there was much coming
back from it and then you know the show
needed to change up but like I don't see
there would be any way that all of us
could have done the show again together
and in my opinion it's my humble right
opinion I think that they kind of went
with like the cheaper group I know I
thought about bringing my fur because of
how cold and shady it would be America I
mean they kind of went with the cheaper
group okay I really appreciate a logical
explanation to choose between two groups
they're gonna like and they have to
bring in Brian cast members and bringing
in new cast I think it was easier to
integrate new cast with the people that
were there like rather than like me and
the twins we're very big personalities
and I think it would have been more new
cast trying to fit in with us rather
than totally so the new cast members do
you know any of them I know all of them
and what are your thoughts
actually I don't know one of them but so
we have first of all from that article
Danielle is coming back which was
misinformation Danielle is coming back
so we have three new casts and they all
work at betches
three yes in some capacity to work
full-time and ones like a contributor
but you know I was pretty I thought it
was just a little ironic this is a new
cast because the only people that those
people knew is me didn't know anybody on
the cast as a friend like they knew them
maybe from interviewing them or from
being a batchest but they didn't know
any of them as a friend they only knew
me that's Soviet so when they were they
up for the like to be on the show even
before you found out that you were no
longer go like was there a better point
when you thought you were gonna be on it
with them I so basically a casting every
year they do casting all these shows do
casting every year even if they don't
bring anybody new and they always like
interview hundreds of people just
because they have to do like due
diligence basically and so they went in
and I had actually introduced Jordan to
production last summer because I was
maybe gonna film with them and it didn't
work out so you know I always knew that
they were in communication but I didn't
really see it I kind of knew from pretty
early on after we were renewed that I
wasn't gonna be coming back so I just
thought you know I kind of ended the
season I had a good season I think you
know there were parts that weren't the
best for me but I think that that was
not my fault I think that a lot of it
was the Edit that I got about at it but
I think I ended at a good place and I
don't think that the shows would have
benefited me anymore on that show very
fair how did your family react to seeing
how they looked on the show that was
difficult I think it was tough for them
because it was kind of like they had to
face how I felt which they never really
experienced because I kind of gave up
telling them that for quite a while like
I would you know it's been a long time
since we had these conversations but I
mean I think they kind of got over a
they you know they realize like how I
feel nothing really has changed
unfortunately but you know I think that
for me it was good because now I feel
like I'm in a place where I can move on
and make decisions knowing that they are
informed yes cuz like it wouldn't be
fair for me to be like [ __ ] you when I
never told them I was mad
you're upset totally so now I feel like
I feels better for me I feel like
lighter and like I can do what I need to
do in regards to my family without like
with being fair to them yeah that's nice
if you could be on any other Bravo show
which would it be and why uh that's a
good one um if I could be on any other
show I would like say Vanderpump rules
because I love all those people but I
would be terrified to be a man from
pearls because they go hardcore they go
hardcore they are like cutthroat you
have to have a thick skin right you know
and you a little forgive easily because
right some of the things these people
have done to each other and now they're
good friends it's like you really have
to be able to move on yeah I love all of
them so much oh I know it'd be so much
fun but I think if I could go on any
other show I would probably do trying to
think I don't know I guess it would be
an improper Olas I feel like it's been a
while since we've gotten like a really
good new format of a show it's true and
I feel like they're working on stuff not
so much as snack but they but we do need
like a new fresh show yeah I think it's
interesting they're kind of changing I'm
really excited for like some of their
scripted stuff that's coming out what's
coming out did you listen to that dirty
Jon podcast no but what [ __ ] and they're
doing it with Connie Britton
I heard that and it's like mystery right
well it's not so much a mystery but it's
it's like a thriller maybe it's gonna be
more like a thriller but like the
podcast I listened to it before I even
knew that the show is being balanced and
it was like I listen to it all in like
two days turning a podcast into a show
let us know if you're interested how
does it feel to be a toaster and to be
in the toaster Facebook group oh my god
I love it and like I don't know if you
guys know but Lauren is I
in the group to so me a lot yes
something like really good like members
of the toasters who you know mostly are
there just to watch but when you're
discussed like you have some Bachelor
people in a2 and it's like oh I didn't
know you were here right I the first
time I ever chimed Dan was when somebody
had leached that Kyle was talking about
us in there at some event or something
and I was just like oh my god but I
loved it and honestly I get most of my
news from there now unless my pop
culture news I just go on there rather
than going to totally because page six
is like not being very good about
updating regularly
no I totally agree and it's like so much
happens that's not like hard news we've
released a press release it's more like
an Instagram comment or like somebody or
an Instagram deletion and like that's a
shady stuff yeah totally what are your
thoughts on Kyle and Amanda well I'm
happy that they have figured out a way
to stay together for them but I think
that they my problem my issue with them
I think is like you know they don't
really they live in a different reality
they cannot separate reality and reality
TV to them I think and what a lot of our
problems stem from is that I don't know
if they had suffered memory loss or what
but it's real guys remember what she
said about getting off the plane yeah as
Lisa Rinna but like I don't know if they
just suffered like amnesia but what
happened during the season and what
aired they they they treat like what is
airing as real life oh that's not what
happened or they like will hold things
that are you know production related or
something against us and they'll try to
bring it up and like on camera corner
you about something in this production
related well you can't really defend
yourself that's annoying talking about
that all the time how like there's this
like elephant in the room about
you know just the fact that you're on a
show right either you talk about it or
you can't talk about it at all right and
it shows have to get very far before
they let them break that wall like
Atlanta can break the walls right but
you know for us it was like we you're
just stuck and you're just kind of like
well obviously you know that they made
me talk about that or obviously you know
they made me do it that's annoying right
well speaking of Kyle a very you know
eloquent and verbose man oh yeah you
told me that he sent you guys an email
yeah I actually um I brought a prop so
one reason why I think that we will
never really be friends again is I got a
17 page email
oh my god from have we got this email
you know and it's just kind of like I I
think he wants to do you know I'm known
for my little truth bombs and grenades
and people can say that I stir [ __ ] or
whatever the fact is I didn't think
about it no one really has ever come for
me that hard on the show and that's
because it's always true like you can't
you can't argue with the truth and he
has tried to come but so much is just
like incorrect or in factual and you
just didn't do that good job
oh my god I'm shook this is one page out
of 17 I've been working on this email
for a month and was hoping to finish it
before any season 3 news hit there was
no easy way to do this conversationally
so I knew it would eventually need to be
sent but I think I waited this long
because I was hoping one of you would
break the silence I can't believe there
are 17 pages of this I have things that
I need to say show or no show because
I'm still trying to make sense of
everything I have never had a
falling-out with a single friend in my
life that's weird friends that's how I
get to be a better friend
totally perhaps this email will shed
light on a few things perhaps it will
make things worse perhaps it will be
read on the mourning toes but all I
really care about are a couple of
friendships that have been years in the
making and getting to the bottom of what
went wrong so here it goes
dr. Tom how do we move on not the show
our friendships how does the silence how
long does the silence need to continue
the fact that I'm the one breaking it
suggests to see you things one none of
you feel that you have done anything
wrong to you feel as though I am
responsible for making the first move
and three an apology may never come
immediately following the taping of
their union was my intention to get all
of us together for a drink because
through thick and thin that's what we
did last summer that's what friends do
and that's why I would assume most
castes you post reading and despite
their differences that's not what
happened instead some of you gathered
without us got kicked out of Village
Tavern great rest oh no is this village
Verna the Greek restroom no this is
Village Tavern like on like seventh
Avenue I don't know it [ __ ] oh great
but great but great and where you got
kicked out of well okay so la reunión
was filmed did you remember that really
bad blizzard in March that the whole
city shut down
well Arbor Union was filmed that day oh
my god you all live here yeah so we we
like literally just like snow plowed our
way to the closed this place we could go
to and then they like closed but yeah
it's already in factual coz then he says
we went to 310 Bowery which we did not
check yeah scruffy aftermath at 3:10
Brett Bowery to the point where I had a
friend check on in on me based on what
had been said we left for my brother's
wedding the next day and my hope was
that some or all of you reach out to
Amanda
today she's done nothing but stick up
for the entire cast at one time or
another put differently she's never done
anything wrong or mean to any of you I
she came on the show once and and she
was very sweet she's a nice person but I
think that like I think she is a very
nice person I think that they just I
think the main problem is is like if
they could separate the show then it
would be like different but I think that
they can't separate it and like a lot of
things came you know I don't know this
so this email goes through like it
breaks it down with his problems by
person by season and this email is sent
to me Lauren Ashley Danielle and Lindsey
and then he sees seed Carl Amin and
Amanda on it just so that they would
know what he wanted to say about us
that's wild he should like be a writer
because who the [ __ ] has the time to do
this really it took him a long time how
how long after the reunion did he send
this he sent
well it's like two months after that on
the reunion oh wow so maybe he is
working on a book this is a segment yeah
that's crazy I think it was just like
you know I don't really find my this is
not how I would deal with friendships if
I even wanted them to be fixed it's by
sending an email like this though
Marasco anyone respond Lindsey I
actually haven't even read it
Wow I look forward to reading this it
might I might need them a few hours yeah
it's very like I think I don't know I
just think is there's a lot of things at
least yeah and that's the size 12 font
there's not skimping there's a lot of
things that go on like where you know I
didn't and in pieces that I've read like
you just can't hold production and what
happened on the show against us
personally if we did something then go
ahead but you know that the way that
things happen like we're not all privy
to each other's conversations and we're
not privy to what producers tell other
people so while I can be mad at you for
something I can't really like attack you
for it because I don't know what the
circumstances were surrounding that
totally that's so tough but like you
need to be able to separate that cuz a
lot of it goes back for me I think a lot
of my problems and and why I like you
know I wasn't so nervous about not doing
it was my big thing with Karl the big
reveal like I just was very bothered
with the way that that came out on TV
because that was not the way and it
happened in real life that big
conversation about the [ __ ] like
that was such a long that was like a
two-hour conversation at this bar that
literally got cut down to one sentence
and I don't think that it ever would
have happened that way if I wasn't a gay
guy saying that yeah you know I think
that the brother took kind of or will
not Bravo our production company it
actually isn't Bravo fall like and a lot
of times my issues would be like I would
go
you know people and they have no idea
because it's only two editors that see
the real footage and then when they
package it up and send it away the
people that are watching don't really
know what really happens they don't
really know if a story was
misrepresented that's so frustrating
like for you I'm just like for us to
know that that's not the full truth
because sometimes like the truth is more
interesting and overshoot you're making
up right I think it we're an ensemble
cast and they want everyone to and you
got it like they don't want anyone to
appear to be a total piece of [ __ ] even
if they are yeah so you know that's why
you get storylines with your mom and
yeah you know things like that like we
this is a more positive question how do
you date in New York City dating apps
friends of friends that's a positive
question do the show make well let's we
want to hear about your dating life do
the show make dating easier or harder I
don't think it really affected how I
guess maybe a little bit harder only
because I'm a little bit more skeptical
but I'm usually that way anyway yeah and
but I'm not I've gone off all my apps
which I had done before that's not
related to the show I actually when we
did the live show I bra guy I was dating
yeah and we broke up in February and
like finally put the nail in the coffin
in April and yeah he was a piece of [ __ ]
what so he seems really nice he was
really nice um I don't know he just got
really weird like he goes Timmy
he literally like I came over and I came
over I had gifts and wine and he
immediately broke up with me I think he
was freaking out like with what he's
gonna do with his life I don't know and
then and then we didn't talk and then we
start talking again and we went on a
dinner
we hung out twice in April and then he
just goes to me so I blocked in my house
someone that
you are actually dating like you can
only go someone if you went on a date or
two and like yeah it's not for you and
it's easier to say nothing than to break
up because there's nothing to break and
he also ghosted another one of his best
friends who is the girl that I brought
to Claudia's birthday so now we're good
friends because we have virtual Hey we
have mutual hate for our ghost a well
that's fantastic thank you for sharing
Ceaser [ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] you
so are you singer single yeah single in
the city and do you respond to your DMS
like if an eligible bachelor were to do
I do
look at my DMS most of them tell me to
go [ __ ] myself but I do look at them
yeah okay so you can slide in feel free
to slide literally we the only thing we
do not talk about Israel houses in New
York which is gearing up for the
momentous Boat episode oh my god and
Carta hey Nia so far looks treacherous
as hell like and the toasters in their
master post we're saying like are you
guys still on Bethany side cuz whose
side have you been on this season
Bethany or Carol I have been on Carol's
side what I have been on Carol side how
have I get to talk to someone who's team
Bethany how do I explain yourself
because B stands a lot for a lot more
than be strong I said hey I'm fine but
like in this instant like she couldn't
be like more pathetic and just like sad
and wounded and it's like Carol I
totally understand everything that
Bethany is hanging like every time she
speaks I understand what she's saying
Carol being smug she is like Carol just
has this like attitude about her that I
just it's I just can't
well I think the difference is is that
Bethany also has an attitude about her
but Bethany in the way her attitude is
very she just will tell you to go [ __ ]
yourself and then move on but she has
not moved on she just starts acting
normal you're all Kerry's like you can
tell she's very like you know she's
stewing in her mind but like this is
just just like this chair pose couldn't
coming to where it's time for everyone
especially Bethany and like I understand
how about these young like unhappy not
comfortable like the house is really
nice but I understand what she's saying
just it's sometimes traveling it's tough
especially when you're not feeling like
the best about like what's going on back
home right I just feel bad for Bethany
going into this trip and just have
everyone railing on her it's like the
timing couldn't be worse
sure I give her that but also Bethany's
a pro at this and she should know to
buckle up and do it like you know first
of all it's probably one of her better
seasons in a while I feel like for
Bethany and so lately well I I mean I
think that I think it's better for her
because she is a focus of a lot of stuff
but she's not being you know she's not
being so bad I feel like it's one of her
worst seasons I feel like every time
they go to a dinner or something it's
like she's always on the defense and
it's like something is doing so majorly
and it's like if she wasn't always
cowering and avoiding conversations like
there's gonna be an explosion
Rad's dropping at least she's here this
time remember this season where
everything was like I gotta go
well that's what I'm feeling now it's
like her the things that are going on in
her personal life like between the
charity Puerto Rico her ex-husband her
custody battle it's so much and it's
like I really feel like she has too much
going on to be doing the show you know
like she really can't be picking up and
going into carta honey or like she needs
to be at home she's moving like all of
this stuff is going on and it's like
she's filming her spin-off with Fredrik
she's going off with Fredrik and I just
feel like most of these women this is
their job filming the show right going
to my mother's and she has so much going
on both good and bad well I mean Ramona
does have her skincare line right that
is true ageless Parana she is ageless
though oh my god Ramona is so funny
and I don't know I just it's all it's
all gonna explode and I'm not looking
forward to be like when Bethenny
apologized to Tinsley in the pool and
like she was literally on the verge of
tears and like everything she said I
completely
she wasn't like doing anything
maliciously wrong and I felt like
Tinsley really did understand and like
forgive her yeah but it's just like it's
the Carroll of it all all soda is not
being a good friend with her ugly shoes
those shoes were so ugly I do think I
saw that they were Chanel even Cheryl
makes mistakes ugly I think Bethany
though does have like I think that I
don't think that Bethany is purposefully
self-absorbed I literally think she just
believes the world revolves around her
because I mean one of the craziest
moments I've seen which wasn't that bad
but when you really think about it was
edgehill's husband's funeral
and somehow Bethany made that about her
I'm like I think she really just
believes like I think she puts all this
pressure on herself yeah that like these
people are mad at me they're mad at me I
don't know like everything's like really
like they don't care but because you
keep talking about them being mad at you
they're getting madder I understand I
know what you mean about it being cringy
at Jill's husband's funeral and I just
felt like it was just so awkward it was
so sad and it was like she was trying to
make a joke and the joke the jokes
weren't weren't happening and she should
not be doing Caroline's on Broadway
right she's no grunge but I just felt
like it was understandable because it
was just such an awkward
sad weird time so I didn't hold that
against her but I do understand what
you're saying yeah but and and I'm going
like and I wasn't always like last
season I could give two shits about
Bethenny this season I just really feel
for her and I feel like no one else is
being sympathetic and like Carole is
acting like a 20 year old right it's not
that deep I think that if Bethenny if
Bethenny showed her emotions more
regularly people may take it as genuine
I think maybe it comes off as being a
little bit more like like a ploy because
she really doesn't show her emotion so
much she comes off very very tough and
so now like when she's trying to it may
come off to the ladies after filming
guys her trying to play victim and maybe
that's why they're being a little bit
more abrasive to her I agree but like
she needs to like whether or not she's
fighting with Drita
she needs to be honest about the fact
that she's going through stuff at home
like because then once you're fighting
with someone you're like I can't take
this I'm going through so much
does sound like a deflection right so I
agree with that but I do also think
she's going to sit and she can't take
this I'm going to see what LuAnn does to
Dorinda
that makes her flip on her next week I'm
dying and you know what I'm really
looking forward to a fight that does not
include Bethenny because this has been
so polarizing for Claudia and I and the
toast and I just want to get it on
another fight and I feel like I'm gonna
be team glam even though like I'm so
excited
and southern charm reunion you watch
other time yeah tonight is the night oh
I don't I feel like Ashley something me
on tonight or like she'll be on the last
three minutes and then like to be
continued I don't know if it's two or
three parts but oh my gosh three parts
is a little heavy a little much but but
there is much to dissect I yeah so
actually some one of our summer house
producers went and did that season
shadowed Sam I think she made it so good
but meaty I really don't have any teeth
but I know that it was she just told me
she's like it's a lot it's a lot there's
so much and there's so much that we see
and like there is so much that we don't
mostly because like there's not enough
time in the day right and I've read and
I've read on toasters some of the like
rumors with and like I don't think that
it's true that none of them are friends
like I saw one post about Craig no sir
yeah I think that they are friends yeah
I think like the boys are definitely I
think the girls I have like became
friends through show and now they're
like co-workers who the right go out to
drinks right and but like I think that
they I don't know I I'm very perplexed
but I'm all I'm very interested to see
how they handle the whole Thomas scandal
if they say anything about it or I mean
they're gonna have to address it he's
not there but I feel like they're like
are they're just gonna tell this is here
or are they gonna actually say something
about the scandal totally and like it'll
be interesting and I think they're still
together that's the craziest part
baffling but I guess
do you read like what wins about that no
like she has [ __ ] on him
Oh like perhaps this sexy big deal
whenever it's crazy when everyone was
talking about the summer house video I
was like I don't know any of the videos
that are out there me I put him out
myself but like I think I actually think
now with Thomas's scandal coming out
it's gonna make them stronger than ever
yeah be created together everyone hates
them together you know nothing unites
people like the world yeah
also if she's standing by Thomas during
this like that how can he ever like
abandon her right without looking like a
piece of [ __ ] right if she is standing
by Thomas turning this that girl will do
anything for a dollar
totally like it's not worth it just get
a job honestly Ryan I know it's not that
hard
yeah I mean it's it's hard but I mean it
be okay
literally when she talks about her job I
know it's not the same but I picture
like you know how they said faith was
like watching some watching some lady I
think you're actually doing the same job
in like having sex for Jax no totally
that's exactly that's like hanging out
and the lady that story is so crazy how
do you watch any of the like challenge
or ex on the beach with faith I've been
watching it because you know faith I
said a lot but it was just so bad nobody
was so bad and I don't mind bad TV but
all right anything let's look at your
pineapple the editing was so fake it was
like they were filming on a beach here
and then on the waterfall and they're
trying to pretend like it's the same day
and I'm like okay I'm not this stupid I
gotta go and like can't we find someone
a little bit more enthused than Romeo
right and like where's Terrence we have
pineapple that's a cut that's so funny
you got a crush the cast of that show
was like really wild like chase from
bachelor bachelor and people said he was
gonna be a man or pump whirls like what
was that oh I have no idea and you were
the one who told us that Karl and Gina
had hooked up right do you know is
Sheena dating either Adam the bartender
or
Robbie he's I did not believe that she's
dating Robbie Hayes there's I don't know
about Adam but I could see that
happening because you know Vanderpump
rules need some new blood and they tried
to tease us with Adam last year and like
the thing with Britney like that the
whole storyline kind of flopped
completely for to make Adam of focus of
the show so I can see how they would
maybe push them to date or something
because Bravo I think is trying to get
more men on their shows and all shows a
urges an upon I think on on a lot of
those shows I mean there's not that many
on travel do you hear about the news oh
I did oh my god you should totally do it
are you gonna well I don't know oh my
god okay well thank you guys so much for
tuning in we will be back tomorrow I
will be with my friend Kristen from page
six so we're just gonna be I love her
isn't she the best
yeah she's such a sweetie and she's also
just an expert on all things pop culture
so we'll be hitting you with the news
that you need to know before you embark
on your weekend Steven you are a true
gem where can everyone follow you you
can follow me just follow me on
Instagram it's you in the game
everything else is worse I agree
have a great day everyone bye
you